Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Es wird alle höchste Zeit, mal wieder auf die Serie A zu blicken. Und mit wem könnte ich das besser tun, als mit Christian Bernhard, unter anderem Serie A-Experte bei der ZOEN und freier Journalist. Ihr lest ihn auch bei der Süddeutschen Zeitung. Und jetzt hört ihr ihn hier im Kurzpass. Christian, schön, dass du mal wieder hier bist.
Ja hallo Max, wunderschönen guten Morgen.
Allerdings, es wurde Zeit mal wieder über die Serie A zu sprechen. Man weiß ja gar nicht, über was man derzeit zuerst reden soll, wenn es um europäischen Fußball geht. Ich mache jetzt auch noch Zweitliga-Kurzpässe. Weiß nicht, ob du das mitgekriegt hast.
Ein Mann, 25 Programme.
Ja, warum auch eigentlich nicht. Warum denn auch eigentlich nicht. Genau, und jetzt wird es aber auch Zeit, dass wir mal über die Serie A sprechen. Denn da ist so viel passiert, seit wir das letzte Mal das im Rasenfunk thematisiert hatten. Zum einen ist Juventus Turin wie aus dem Nichts Meister geworden.
Damit konnte wirklich niemand rechnen.
Ich wollte eigentlich eine Emergency-Sendung machen, aber es ging dann sich leider zeitlich nicht aus. Aber um den Spaß kurz beiseite zu tun, Juve zwar Meister geworden, aber in der Zwischenzeit auch gegen Ajax in der Champions League ausgeschieden. Und da frage ich dich als Serie-A-Experten, wie konnte denn das passieren?
Ja gut, wie das passieren konnte, glaube ich, sieht man jetzt ja, was Ajax so allgemein in den letzten Monaten so aufzieht. Also, um das kurz einzuordnen, klar war das eine riesen Enttäuschung für Juve, keine Frage. Ich meine, die hatten ja schon seit mehreren Jahren diesen Plan. Auch evtl. vielleicht insgeheim, ohne es direkt auszusprochen, diesen Pott endlich wieder nach Turin zu holen. Und in dieser Saison auch mit diesem Herrn aus Portugal, der am Sommer verpflichtet wurde, waren die Vorzeichen jetzt sicherlich nicht schlechter geworden. Aber man muss jetzt, glaube ich, auch einfach sagen, erst mal so wie Ajax gespielt hat und wenn man sich das Ganze auch anschaut, wenn man erst Real rausnimmt und dann Juve rausnimmt und die beide auch noch auswärts rausnimmt und wenn man jetzt anschaut, dass die womöglich nur noch einen Schritt davon entfernt sind, noch was ganz anderes zu reißen, dann muss man da halt einfach auch den Hut ziehen. Und das ist auch wirklich, finde ich, eine schöne Geschichte. Wie gesagt, Enttäuschung bei Juve, riesig. Keine Frage, das war auch ja, drei Tage danach sind sie ja Meister geworden, haben die Meisterschaft endgültig eingetütet und da lag logisch schon so ein Schleier drüber, keine Frage. Aber sowohl Allegri-Trainer als auch der Präsident Agnelli, und das ist, glaube ich, auch eine schöne Entwicklung, die sich da auch ein bisschen getan hat. Die haben sofort anerkannt, dass Ajax das einfach verdient hat und haben einfach den Hut vor denen gezogen, wie sie das quasi spielerisch gemacht haben, was da dahinter steckt. Und ja, das ist eine Entwicklung, die vielleicht in Italien nicht immer Usus ist. Und deswegen würde ich sagen, glaube ich, hat auch Juve daraus, weil die Diskussionen danach die gab es und die gibt es immer noch, auch sicher war es vielleicht ein bisschen was mit rausgezogen, was man da vielleicht auch am eigenen Tun vielleicht in der Zukunft etwas ändern könnte.
Das würde mich jetzt noch interessieren.
Das ist philosophisch.
Weil wenn der Präsident und vor allem der Trainer den Gegner loben, dann retten die damit ja indirekt auch immer so ein bisschen die eigene Haut. Ich fand schon, also ich war überrascht davon, wie Juve die zweite Halbzeit gegen Ajax gespielt hat. Also, dass sie da keinen Stich gesehen haben, dass es nur eine Frage der Zeit war, bis irgendwie Ajax das entscheidende Tor macht. Und ich habe Juventus Turin in der Vergangenheit immer als eine Mannschaft erlebt, die in solchen Situationen einen kühnen Kopf bewahrt und dann nicht immer mit den schönsten aller fußballerischen Mittel, aber dann auch einfach mal zuschlägt. Einfach mal irgendein Standard reinhaut oder vielleicht auch einfach mal sich so sehr auf die Defensive konzentriert, dass man den Gegner im Keim erstickt. Warum kam denn da keine Reaktion bzw. wie wurde denn das wahrgenommen vom Umfeld von Juve, diese zweite Halbzeit und dann das Ausscheiden?
Also das wurde definitiv sehr kontrovers oder auch sehr in ganz Fußball Italien auch sehr heißblütig diskutiert. Genau das war es ja, denn die Art und Weise, wie das passiert ist. Du führst dann auch noch im Rückspiel, dann fällt dieser relativ glückliche Ausgleich. Aber das ist ja auch mei, das ist ja egal. Juve hat auch viele solcher Tore geschossen, also das passiert. Und dann, genau, wie du richtig gesagt hast, haben sie eigentlich keinen Fuß mehr in der zweiten Hälfte aufs Parkett bekommen. Und das ist ja auch die Sache, die dann am heißesten diskutiert wurde. Da wurde logisch auch Allegri Stand sofort zur Diskussion, was ja klar ist, wenn du mit diesem riesen Kader dann quasi halt dieses Stil dann doch vielleicht gegen einen nicht so großen Namen und doch vielleicht eine Runde zu früh sozusagen aus den Augen verlierst. Und klar wurde da auch dieser Spielstil, Spielphilosophie-Frage gleich mal in den Raum geworfen, weil du eben dieses Gegenbeispiel hattest, diese jungen Villen da, die einen sehr klaren Plan hatten und die diesen auch mit sehr viel Lebensfreude und Euphorie sozusagen belebt haben. Und das, glaube ich, wird auch die große Herausforderung sein für Allegri, dass sie das gemeinsam versuchen, da sozusagen die Antwort darauf zu finden. Und Juve wird jetzt sicher nicht von heute auf morgen auch so ein Hurra-Stil spielen, also das müssen sie auch gar nicht. Aber wie du richtig gesagt hast, in dem Moment eigentlich keine Antwort darauf zu haben, das hat sich schon tief getroffen, keine Frage. Und wie gesagt, ich meine, so was kann man ja nicht innerhalb von zwei, drei Spielen beantworten, schon gar nicht jetzt in der Saison, wo ihr alles schon durchlässt.
Ja, da ist ja jetzt alles weg. Aber rechnest du da mit einem größeren Umbruch? Also geht es dann da um Personal oder geht es um Philosophie? Wie ist da so die Analyse gelaufen? Oder kam Juve auch zu dem Ergebnis, was man hier in Deutschland ja dann noch gerne mal hat, Mensch, denen fehlen einfach in der Liga die Gegner und dann können sie ja auch international nicht mehr brauchen?
Also, nee, das scheint jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so groß im Vordergrund. Es ist schon – Allegri wird in Italien nicht erst seit diesem Spiel, das läuft schon länger, kriegt immer wieder auch mal ordentlich Kritik von mehreren Seiten, von wegen, ja, ihr gewinnt seit Jahren alles, ja, ihr seid in Italien dominant, aber so eine richtige Spielidee oder für was Juve jetzt genau steht, fragen viele auch, wissen wir jetzt rein spielerisch nicht unbedingt. Und diese Diskussionen wurden logisch durch dieses Resultat noch mal krass befeuert. Man hat auch gemerkt, zum Beispiel jetzt letzte Woche nach Juve gegen Inter gegen Juve, gab es einen ziemlich offenen Disput von Allegri mit einem TV-Experten, die sich vor laufender Kamera ja schon ziemlich offensiv beharkt haben. Also man merkt, da ist noch viel Nervosität da und Allegri fühlt sich da auch manchmal so ein bisschen in die Ecke getrieben, weil er dann halt immer kommt, ja Jungs, schaut euch mal an, was ich gewonnen habe. Für mich ist es entscheidend, wenn man am Ende gewinnt, dann… Also diese Frage stand schon länger im Raum und die bekam jetzt logisch neues Futter, keine Frage. Und da wird sich jetzt definitiv zeigen, klar, es werden Namen diskutiert. Also um zurückzukommen, also einen riesen Umbruch sehe ich bei Juve nicht. Aber es werden sicher ein paar Stellschrauben gedreht und vielleicht gerade auch dieses spielerische Element, gerade im Mittelfeld vielleicht auch versucht sozusagen ein bisschen neuen, ja, einen neuen Drive reinzubekommen. Allegra hat zum Beispiel schon angekündigt, jetzt in den letzten Spielen so ein bisschen, zum Beispiel Bernadeski und auch Cancelo, wo man jetzt nicht unbedingt damit rechnen würde, im Mittelfeld testen zu wollen, weil er ihnen da zutraut, so auch auf der Achterposition oder auf der Halbposition das ein bisschen zu spielen. Also er macht sich definitiv Gedanken, der ganze Verein macht sich Gedanken und im Idealfall würde ich mal sagen aus Jubelsicht, wenn sie da die richtigen Schlüsse daraus ziehen und vielleicht auch wirklich sehen, was ja auch vielleicht mit einer ganz krassen oder halt mit einer klar definierten Spielidee möglich ist. Vielleicht kann man da aus dieser schweren Niederlage ja vielleicht dann auch mittelfristig was Gutes rausziehen.
Ja, müsste man jetzt auch mal dann ins Detail gehen. Also da bin ich sehr gespannt, es wäre, das ist jetzt eine Arbeitsthese, die ich habe, ich glaube es wäre aber der erste Verein, bei dem Cristiano Ronaldo spielt, der für eine klare Philosophie steht, die darüber hinausgeht, bringe den Ball irgendwie zu ihm nach vorne, egal ob in der Luft oder tief, versuche ihn irgendwie ins 1 gegen 1 zu bringen.
Ja, also ich würde mal sagen, jetzt in diesem einem Juve-Jahr, ich würde gar nicht sagen, dass Juve wirklich alles komplett auf Ronaldo ausgeregt hat, also habe ich so nicht gesehen, was aber Fakt ist, und da brauchen wir sich auch nur die Statistik anschauen, ich glaube, ich bin mir jetzt nicht zu 100% sicher, aber zu 90% dass Ronaldo die letzten vier Champions-League-Tore von Juve in dieser Saison geschossen hat, die sie allgemein geschossen haben, oder die sie überhaupt geschossen haben, oder fünf sogar, dann ist logisch auch die Frage, ja gut, alles allein kann der gute Mann halt auch nicht machen, also das wäre halt schon auch ganz praktisch, gerade weil ja bei Juve schon auch noch ein bisschen an Qualität ja was noch rumläuft, wenn da halt auch ein bisschen Unterstützung käme sozusagen, wenn wir jetzt nur ums reine Abschluss sozusagen, reine Abschlussqualitäten sprechen. Also Ronaldo hat sich da wunderbar eingefügt, viele sehen jetzt die Tore, hat aber auch gerade am Anfang der Saison oder mittel drin auch sehr viel gut harmoniert, hat auch viele Tore vorbereitet, also ich habe ihn jetzt gar nicht so als den großen Ego-Zocker wahrgenommen oder der, um den sich alles drehen muss. Fakt ist, das soll auch keine Ausrede sein, das hat auch Juve gleich gesagt, aber in entscheidendem Phase haben dann doch auch ein paar offensiv Leute gefehlt, so wie Quadrado, wie man zugeht, Spiel Douglas Costa, die sicherlich auch ganz gut getan hätten, das soll aber überhaupt nicht als Ausrede gelten, in anderen Mannschaften fehlen auch sehr wichtige Spieler, also aber es waren ein paar Optionen weniger und gerade zum Beispiel so das Tempo von Douglas Costa, das hat man im Hinspiel gesehen, als er reinkam, das ist gegen so eine Mannschaft wie Ajax schon auch ganz brauchbar, wenn die merken, okay die anderen haben auch einen, der mit einem Antritt da ein paar Lücken reißen kann oder so. Ja, da kam einiges zusammen, aber über kurz über lang, wie gesagt, das war völlig verdient von Ajax und ja, ich kann, wenn es Juve richtig macht und nochmal, man braucht jetzt logisch auch nicht die Juve-Realität mit der Ajax-Realität vergleichen, das ist klar, aber ich glaube, ein paar Ansätze oder Anstöße haben sie da vielleicht schon rausgezogen und ja, schauen, ob sie die auch umsetzen können.
Vielleicht auch einfach nochmal dann beim Trainer dahingehend umorientieren, dass man sich jemanden holt, der ungeschlagen gegen Ajax durch die Champions-League-Saison gegangen ist, Niko Kovac vom FC Bayern.
Zum Beispiel, da gibt es wenige, aber sehr hoch klingende Beispiele.
Also die letzten fünf Tore, da hattest du natürlich völlig recht, 3 gegen Atletico hat Cristiano Ronaldo gemacht und dann das beide Tore gegen Ajax in beiden Spielen. Wenn wir jetzt dann weiter auf die Tabelle gucken, dann sehen wir, dass da Napoli mit 18 Punkten Rückstand, aber dann wiederum mit 11 Punkten Vorsprung bzw. 12 Punkten Vorsprung auf den erst nicht Champions-League-Platz sehr sicher auf Platz 2 steht. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das das spannende Thema ist oder Inter. Worüber würdest du jetzt am liebsten sprechen? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, als es um die Champions-League-Qualifikation geht oder um den letzten Champions-League-Platz.
Ich finde auch, dass das mit Abstand das spannendste Thema ist. Wir können in Napoli zum Beispiel relativ schnell abhaken. Die spielen so ein bisschen eine Saison im hochqualitativen Niemandsland, keine Frage. Das Schlimmste für Neapel oder aus dem Neapel-Umfeld, das mit Abstand wahrscheinlich das heißblütigste ist, ist, dass in den letzten Wochen auch in der Mannschaft wirklich eine Indifferenz gegenübergetragen wurde. Ja, also noch mal auf hohem Niveau. Weil Juve war halt einfach schon seit Wochen, seit Monaten einfach out of reach. Und dann gab es ja doch eine Phase, wo Angela, wo sie auch die Mannschaft spielerisch sehr gut gemacht hat, auch Angela, die einfach diese neuden kleinen Impulse rein gebracht hat, aber trotzdem noch vieles von dem, von Sarri, einfach logisch weitergeführt hat, weil er ein sehr cleverer Mann ist. Aber in den letzten Wochen ist da doch so ein bisschen Sand ins Getriebe bekommen, dann war ja auch ein bisschen diese Hoffnung vielleicht über die Europa League. Gerade Ancelotti, auch ein Trainer, der ja sehr über den Europapokal sich auch definiert.
Das war aber dann relativ deutlich mit 0 zu 2 und 0 zu 1.
Und ja, auch in der Liga, was ich Ihnen jetzt, glaube ich, gar nicht vorwerfen würde, wollen würde, weil klar, Juve war, das Ding war durch und von hinten kommt halt auch nicht so viel Druck. Gab es halt auch ein paar Ergebnisse, die jetzt nicht unbedingt, wo sich Napoli mit Ruhm bekleckert hat. Und dadurch war ein bisschen so, weil die Fanszene auch so, de Laurent ist immer ein bisschen skeptisch gegenübersteht. Und dann war das halt auch so ein bisschen, die Zuschauerzahlen sind auch nicht wirklich prickelnd. Also, ich glaube, bei Napoli geht es einfach darum, jetzt im Sommer dann einfach wieder diese Euphorie anzufachen, was aber normalerweise auch ohne Probleme funktioniert. Denn dafür ist diese Stadt halt auch bekannt. Ja, es braucht wirklich nur diesen einen kleinen Funken, um wieder ein bisschen Hoffnung zu haben. Und dann werden sie dieses Projekt wieder angehen und versuchen auch nächstes Jahr einfach Juve halt irgendwie dann doch vielleicht irgendwann da runterzustoßen und sich noch mal so eine Sausse zu garantieren, wie sie Diego Armando Maradona vor drei Jahrzehnten dann in der Stadt...
Vielleicht nicht mit allen Details, die man über diese Sausse so nachsieht.
Aber ich glaube, sie würden auch da was Interessantes hinbekommen in die Stadt.
Okay, also Napoli auf Platz zwei mit 18 Punkten Rückstand auf Juve, aber eben auch genügend Vorsprung auf die Ränge dahinter. Dann folgt auf Rang drei Inter. Die sind die Einzigen, die gerade so ein kleines Pöstelchen haben, was die Champions League-Plätze angeht. Aber es ist klein. 62 Punkte. Und um ein kurzes Tabellenbild vollständig zu machen für die Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen. Platz vier Atalanta, das ist der letzte Champions League-Platz. 59 Punkte. Platz fünf aktuell Roma. 58 Punkte. Platz sechs Turin. 56 Punkte. Geteilt mit 56 Punkten auf Platz sieben mit Milan und Lazio hat 55 Punkte. Das heißt, vom Champions League-Platz Nummer – nehmen wir ruhig Inter mit rein. Vom dritten Platz mit 62 Punkten bis zum achten Platz, für den du dann gar nichts mehr bekommst, auch keine Euro League, liegen sieben Punkte. Wie sicher ist Inter denn da oben situiert? Es sieht da gerade von der Tabellenkonstellation für Inter am besten aus.
Ja, klar, es sind nicht viele Punkte, wie du völlig richtig sagst, aber auch wenn man sich das Restprogramm anschaut, es gibt noch ein paar direkte Duelle. Also Inter ist jetzt rein theoretisch schon relativ fest im Sattel, aber es ist auch Inter.
Was soll denn das heißen?
Ja, Inter hat nicht umsonst in Italien Pazza Inter, also das verrückte Inter. Also das sollte man sich nie allzu sicher sein. Aber ich glaube, die Amten muss man auch fairerweise sagen, da gab es ja auch, da wurde ja in den letzten Monaten oft nicht unbedingt über gespielten Fußball diskutiert, sondern mehr über Geschichten drum herum. Aber gerade in den letzten paar Spieltagen haben sie auch wieder ein bisschen gefangen. Sie haben gerade auch jetzt zum Beispiel gegen Juve echt lange Zeit, über eine Halbzeit lang wirklich eine sehr starke Leistung gezeigt und haben auch zuletzt wieder gepunktet. Und ich bin mir sicher, dass sie sich das jetzt nicht mehr nehmen lassen. Also die werden dieses Champions League-Ding eintüten. Und dann gibt es ja logisch auch einige Fragen zu klären im Sommer. Die allergrößte fängt mit Mauro an und hört mit Icardi auf. Ja, wie gesagt, und klarerweise – und das ist ja auch das Schöne, da können wir jetzt auch gleich darüber reden, wenn wir über diesen ganzen Champions League-Wulst sprechen – es tut sich auch einiges auf den Trainerbänken von mehreren Mannschaften. Und da ist so ein Name, nämlich der von Antonio Conte, der so ein bisschen über diesem ganzen Kosmos schwebt. Da gibt es einige Berührungspunkte. Das wird so ein bisschen sozusagen der Kronprinz wahrscheinlich werden, der dann womöglich da alles Mögliche ein bisschen verschiebt. Und da gibt es echt, also auch über die Saison hinaus, glaube ich, Richtung Sommer wird es da echt einige interessante Wendungen geben.
Spannend. Dann lass uns doch mal auf die Mannschaft gucken, die aktuell auf dem Champions League-Platz liegt, nämlich Atalanta, die jetzt auch schon seit ewigen Zeiten einen Lauf eigentlich haben. Also aus den letzten sechs Spielen zum Beispiel vier Siege, zwei Unentschieden, keine Niederlage. Das sind die Mannschaften, bei der man immer hingucken kann. Das haben wir ja auch schon häufig genug hier in den Serie-A-Kurzpässen thematisiert. Also aktuell hat man 109 Tore gesehen, wenn man Spiele mit Atalanta sich angeguckt hat. 68 haben sie geschossen, 42 kassiert. Also da geht nach vorne und nach hinten was. Das wirkt so ein bisschen, als wären die diejenigen, die von hinten nach oben geschoben haben und damit alle anderen Vereine unter Stress setzen.
Siehst du, meine Augenbrauen so ein bisschen bling-bling machen.
Also ich sehe vor allem deine Augen funkeln.
Ja, also ich muss, also was Atalanta da, jetzt mittlerweile ist ja nicht nur diese Saison, das ging ja letzte Saison auch schon los. Also was die da abreißen, das ist schon, würde ich mal sagen, ganz, ganz großes Kino. Also was die Eigentümer schafft, Präsident Percasse heißt das, auch sein Sohn ist Sportdirektor, die stammen aus Bergamo, das ist alles sehr verwurzelt da sozusagen, zusammen mit Gasperini eben, dem großen Architekten auf der Bank. Also was die da jetzt wirklich auch eben, wie gesagt, weil das ist ja nicht eine Ausreißersaison, sondern das hat sich ja wirklich peu à peu angekündigt. Und wenn man die…
Letzte Saison schon in Europa liegt?
Genau, wenn man sich zurück erinnert, hat glaube ich zwei Minuten am Gegendortmund gefehlt, um die rauszunehmen in der K.o. Runde. Also das ist schon, also es ist echt beeindruckend, was die da leisten. Denn ich finde, was ich so beeindruckend finde, du hast sie angesprochen, sie haben zusammen mit Juventum den besten Sturm. Also sind jetzt definitiv nicht ganz so stabil, aber Gasperini hat es geschafft, was ich so in Italien, würde ich sagen, in dieser Intensität, glaube ich, lange nicht mehr gesehen habe. Also Gasperini ist einer dieser, also hoch angesehener Trainer in Italien schon seit vielen Jahren. Also der hat auch sozusagen das taktische Handwerk, all diese positiven Eigenschaften, die italienischen Trainern oft zugewiesen werden, die bringt er alle mit. Das ist ein klarer Plan, die Jungs auf dem Platz wissen ganz genau, was sie zu tun haben. Das ist alles organisiert, aber – und jetzt kommt der Punkt – der hat dann noch ein neues Element mit reingebracht oder das Ganze mit einer brutalen Intensität gepaart oder gefüttert. Oft ist ja vielleicht dann viel auch manchmal, wenn man es jetzt negativ sehen will, was ich gar nicht so empfinde, aber wird vielleicht manchmal so, wird ein bisschen so wie auf dem Schachbrett viel verschoben und so. Das Ganze muss vielleicht nicht immer unter dem höchsten Tempo sein, aber wenn du dir ein Atalanta-Spiel anschaust, da ist eben wie gesagt diese Struktur ist klar zu erkennen, die ist da, aber das Ganze ist in höchstem Tempo, mit positiv gemeint Aggressivität, Intensität, da wird angelaufen als Gegner. Du hast keine ruhige Sekunde, die laufen dich von allen Seiten an. Wenn es Ballgewinne gibt, schwärmen die aus. Also ich kann es jedem nur ans Herz legen, schaut euch mal ein Atalanta-Spiel an. Also das ist wirklich, allein in dieser Saison, ich habe mehrere Atalanta-Spiele auch kommentieren dürfen. Es gab nicht eins, wo ich gesagt hatte, ja gut, es war halt ein Fußballspiel. Sondern da war immer so viel Rabatz im Positiven. Klar, dann sind auch manchmal so kleine Jugendzünden, dann lassen die viel liegen und so. Aber wie die immer weitermachen, was die sich rausspielen, die sich im Kopf nicht hängen lassen, das ist wirklich, also vom Charakter und auch einfach, ich würde einfach Intensität drüber schreiben, also wirklich ganz, ganz großen Respekt, was die da abfeuern.
Mit Duván Zapata aktuell ein der besten Torjäger der Liga mit 21 Toren, aber auch dahinter hört es jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig schnell auf. Also das ist einfach eine offensiv starke Mannschaft.
Ja, das ist ein Kollektiv und es geht schon damit los, da schalten sich auch die Innenverteidiger zum Beispiel sehr oft, also nicht nur bei Standards, dass die mit vorgehen, der Klassiker, sondern da siehst du auch wirklich oft welche aus der Dreierkette dann am gegnerischen Strafraum rumturnen, um da auch nochmal spielerisch sozusagen einzugreifen. Also die haben relativ spätstarke Innenverteidiger auch, die dann auch wirklich den letzten Pass auch teilweise oder im vorderen Drittel auch noch mit eingreifen. Das ist wirklich ein Konstrukt, das einfach schön anzuschauen ist. Und wenn man das mit den Mitteln halt jetzt einfach vergleicht, das ist ja immer noch Atalanta. Und wenn die da jetzt da mit Inter, Roma, Milan, einfach da wirklich die ganze Saison jetzt schon mitteilen – und man darf ja nicht vergessen, sie stehen noch im Coppa Italia-Finale. Also die Saison ist ja eh schon Wahnsinn, aber die können da was richtig, richtig Großes jetzt halt noch in diesen letzten Wochen einfahren.
Das ist ja ein bisschen die Eintracht Frankfurt-Situation der Serie A, ne?
Ja, also wie gesagt, du wirst da auch glaube ich wenig Leute finden, die in Italien – also Atalanta hat wirklich auch vielen so ein bisschen wieder so ein Lächeln ins Gesicht gezaubert, weil wie gesagt, weil das ja auch mit Ansage kam. Das ist ja nicht so einfach plötzlich, wie plötzlich, oh wir sind jetzt hier und wir wissen nicht, sondern da steckt Struktur dahinter. Zabate zum Beispiel hast du angesprochen, ja das ist der, der das dann filmisiert. Der hat glaube ich vor kurzem war der mal, hatte der die Statistik im Kalenderjahr 2019, hatte nur Messi öfter in der Liga getroffen als er. Also das ist einer, der hat glaube ich erst im Dezember angefangen mit dem regelmäßigen Tore schießen und jetzt steht er bei 21. Also das, ja, also wirklich eine richtig schöne Geschichte und auch mit einem kleinen deutschen Beitrag, denn Robin Goossens ist eben auch einer von diesen, die da gerade eben die auf außen, wo er ja auch beheimatet ist, die machen da richtig schön Meter und ja, ist halt auch einer von denen, die vielleicht, die man nicht auf der Rechnung hatte bis vor ein, zwei Jahren, aber die eben auch und das ist auch das Schöne, die haben halt allein, ich glaube Atalanta hieß es jetzt mal kurz vor kurzem eine Studie bei der Gazzetta, die haben den Marktwert des Mannschafts in dieser Saison verdoppelt. Und diese ganzen Derrondts und so, das sind Harteböer, das sind holländische Nationalspieler mittlerweile, die haben auch schon gegen Deutschland gespielt. Also da ist auch Qualität dahinter, Freuler im Zentrum, Schweizer Nationalspieler, also und das haben die aber sozusagen aus sich selbst herausentwickelt, also ich kann nur jeden Hut, der bei mir rumliegt, davor ziehen.
Da hat man jetzt schon einen Eindruck von bekommen, wenn wir jetzt gucken, gegen wen Atalanta noch spielt, weil die große Frage ist ja, trägt sich das denn noch bis zum Ende oder könnte dieses Konstrukt daran zerfallen, dass man vielleicht nicht die Champions League erreicht und dann ja auch gewisse Spieler nicht halten kann. Also da würde ich jetzt auch eine Parallele zur Eintracht Frankfurt ziehen wollen. Dann sehen wir, okay, es geht auswärts gegen Lazio, das sind eben die, die am dringendsten Punkte brauchen, die sind gerade am weitesten entfernt von den internationalen Plätzen. Dann zu Hause gegen Genoa, auswärts bei Juve und zu Hause gegen Sassuolo. Wie würdest du das einordnen? Du kennst ja auch die Restprogramme der anderen besser. Wie gut sind die Chancen, dass Atalanta da seinen Pünktchen Vorsprung irgendwie über die Runden bringt?
Erstens mal, und das ist auch schön, das haben die auch relativ offensiv gesagt, also jetzt überhaupt nicht arrogant, sondern hat einfach, ja, seit letzten Wochenende haben wir es einfach selbst in der Hand, denn das liegt jetzt an uns. Und das sagt auch ein bisschen was aus, also sie verstecken sich da jetzt nicht so hinter von wegen. Also selbst vor ein paar Wochen, als sie noch ein paar Punkte Rückstand haben, ist immer so ein bisschen mitgeschwebt, ja, wir versuchen da schon noch ran zu kratzen. Also es sagt auch viel über das Selbstverständnis aus. Ja, klar, das Restprogramm. Aber das Schöne ist, du hast Juve angesprochen, Juve spielt an den letzten vier Spieltagen gegen drei dieser Kandidaten. Also die haben jetzt am Wochenende das Derby gegen Turin, dann spielen sie auch noch gegen die Roma, gegen Atalanta. Es gibt auch noch andere direkte Duelle, also sich da jetzt irgendwie eine Prognose zu wagen, finde ich sehr, sehr schwierig. Ich traue Atalanta definitiv zu, weil die schweben einfach auf so einer Welle. Aber diese Welle ist jetzt nicht nur rein euphorisch bedingt, sondern wie gesagt, da gibt es ein fixes Fundament. Aber ich sehe jetzt keinen Grund. Also ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass die jetzt plötzlich auf der Ziellinie einbrechen werden. Die Frage ist logisch immer, was macht auch die Konkurrenz? Klar, wenn da jetzt die Roma oder Milan doch sich entscheiden sollte, alle vier Spiele noch zu gewinnen, dann wird es logisch schwer. Auch Viertel-Atalanta, keine Frage. Aber ich traue sie definitiv zu.
Die Grundvoraussetzungen sind da. Und man sollte eines der Spiele gegen Lazio, Genua, Juve oder Sassuolo sich definitiv angucken, wenn man guten Fußball sehen möchte. Was würde man denn sehen, wenn man sich die Roma anschaut, die aktuell mit 58 Punkten ein Pünktchen hinter dem Champions League-Platz liegt?
Das ist eine gute Frage, denn das weiß man so bei der Roma ungefähr nie. Wieder mal eine Wundertüten-Saison, ein paar Exzellents. Sie haben auch zuletzt unter Ranieri ein bisschen Stabilität rein bekommen, was für die Roma schon relativ viel ist. Eine wilde Saison, logischerweise wieder Trainerwechsel. Die Francesco, der sie letztes Jahr ins Champions League-Halbfinale geführt hat. Monchi ist mittlerweile weg, der einen sehr großen personellen Umbruch vorangetrieben hat. Die Roma ist einfach schwer zu greifen. Das wird sich auch in den letzten Spielen für die Roma – wäre es logisch unfassbar wichtig – in den Champions League reinzukommen. Keine Frage, das gilt für die Medien auch, wo wir auch noch dazukommen. Da geht es ja auch um finanzielle Geschichten sozusagen. Da können wir jetzt vielleicht wirklich den Bogen spannen, denn dieser Name Antonio Conte, der eben sowohl bei Inter schon länger im Gespräch war, weil da ist ja auch die Frage, ob das mit Spalette überhaupt weitergeht und so. Aber in den letzten Tagen oder jetzt wirklich relativ aktuell heißt das, dass die Roma sehr, sehr intensiv an Conte dran ist. Und allein das hat dazu geführt, dass wieder so ein bisschen Euphorie. Die Roma ist auch – also Rom ist eine Fußballstadt, ähnlich wie Neapel – da gibt es weder Himmel hoch jauchzend oder zu Tor betrübt. In der Mitte ist da relativ wenig Platz für so ein bisschen Gleichgewicht. Und das hat so wieder für Euphorie gesorgt. Denn logisch, wenn so ein Mann wie Conte kommen würde, dann wäre klare Ansage, dass die definitiv da ganz oben dran bleiben wollten. Und allein Conte, glaube ich, würde auch gar nicht kommen, wenn diese Möglichkeiten gar nicht da wären. Und deswegen hängen da auch viele Namen dran. Jeko zum Beispiel, Manolas hinten drin. Also, das wird sich jetzt viel. Es heißt, in italienischen Medien wird spekuliert, dass sich das vielleicht am 12. Mai spielt, die Juve gegen die Roma. Angeblich hat Conte es so ein bisschen durchblicken lassen, dass er sich bis dahin entscheiden möchte. Und das wäre logisch ein Riesenschub. Also, wenn die Roma es wirklich schaffen würde, Conte zu holen, dann wäre das eine große Nummer.
Aber sagen wir mal, Roma hat ja schon mal den Trainer gewechselt. Ja. In dieser Saison.
Es geht jetzt logisch Richtung nächste Saison.
Genau. Ja, aber was sagt denn das jetzt über den aktuellen Trainer aus?
Ja, das Schöne muss man dazu sagen, Ranieri ist ja gebürtiger Römer. Römer durch und durch hat das auch so ein – Freundschaftsdienst ist jetzt ein großes Wort – der ist da eingesprungen in einer nicht einfachen Situation.
Okay.
Es ist nicht die klassische Interim-Solution, nicht falsch verstehen. Also Ranieri hätte ganz sicher kein Problem, auch nächstes Jahr die Roma zu führen. Nur das Schöne ist, als diese Gerüchte immer intensiver wurden, hat sich Ranieri hingestellt, was halt auch viel über seinen Stil aussucht und hat gemeint, wenn das mit Kontest stimmt, dann bin ich der Erste, der zum Flughafen fährt und ihn abholt. Denn ich wüsste, dass das für einen Verein eine sehr, sehr, sehr gute Sache wäre. Also Ranieri ist da sehr, sage ich mal, Older-States-Mann-mäßig, geht er da ran. Der hat das volle Vertrauen, gerade auch Totti war anscheinend, der mittlerweile in der Funktionärsrolle war, war eine treibende Kraft, dass auch Ranieri zurückholen wollte, weil er wusste, das passt, die kennen sich alle, Ranieri, Totti, De Rossi, das ist eine enge Pindung. Aber Ranieri selbst hat gemeint, also wie gesagt, wenn das mit Kontest konkret werden sollte, dann würde er sich da definitiv nicht grämen oder einen Weg stellen.
Gut, diese Frage habe ich mir nämlich gerade gestellt. Und dann sehen wir eben, dass bei der Roma auch immer viel los ist. 61 Tore geschossen, aber 46 kassiert. Das ist halt das große Aber bei der Roma. Ansonsten sieht das ja alles ganz gut aus. Es ist jetzt auch nichts Neues. Aber es ist ja auch nicht komplett überraschend, wenn man sich anguckt, welche Abgänge man zu verzeichnen hatte. Also wenn man die Mannschaft jetzt vergleichen wollen würde, mit der aus der letzten Saison, die dann gegen Liverpool im Halbfinale stand, dann fehlen da halt auch einfach entscheidende Spiele. Nicht zuletzt der hinten Anderson im Tor. Das heißt, ganz überraschend kann das doch jetzt auch nicht sein, dass es jetzt eine schwierige Saison werden würde.
Nee, keine Frage. Du sagst ja, das zieht sich so ein bisschen bei der Roma wie ein roter Faden, auch über mehrere Jahre. Bei der Roma, würde ich mal sagen, im Vergleich zu vielen anderen großen italienischen Vereinen, also so viel Umbruch wie bei der Roma, verlässlich fast Jahr für Jahr, das hast du eigentlich fast nirgends. Und Monchi hat das bei all dem Fußballverständnis und dem Fachwissen, das der Mann ja definitiv hat, deswegen hat er ja zu Recht auch diesen sehr hohen Ruf. Das war halt einfach ein sehr, sehr großer Umbruch. Du hast ja alles so angesprochen, da war auch noch Nain Golan. Man muss sich hier nur mal die Historie anschauen, was die Roma in den letzten sechs, sieben Jahren, was die ihren Innenverteidigern hervorgebracht haben, die mittlerweile in Europa bei allen großen Vereinen, also wenn man das kurz nur, das ging los mit Marquinhos, der war damals bei der Roma, jetzt bei PSG. Dann ging es weiter mit Benatia, der dann über Bayern zu Juve, mit Romagnoli, der jetzt Milan-Kapitän ist, mit Rüdiger, der dann zu Chelsea. Jedes Jahr im Prinzip wurde so die Abwehrstütze weg. Also das ist so ein Klassiker zum Beispiel. Und klar, die haben dann oft, die haben Geld gemacht, dann haben sie auch wieder viel Geld in die Hand genommen. Es ist ein bisschen ein Kuddelmuddel, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, wenn man es, also immer sehr viel Aktionismus auch dabei. Und vielleicht wäre Conte da wirklich der richtige Mann, um da halt einfach mal ein bisschen Stabilität reinzubringen. Es heißt, dass er, er ist ja in einer sehr, sehr guten Verhandlungsposition, da vielleicht wirklich auch so fast so, wie man es aus England ja kennt, dann vielleicht auch so wirklich das Personal, das Ganze wirklich, zumindest da sehr groß den Damen drauf hat. Also und ja, vielleicht wäre das ja genau das, was so ein Verein braucht, dass da einfach mal versucht wird, ein bisschen personelle Stabilität reinzubekommen.
Ja, schauen wir, wo es für die Roma hingeht. Es kann doch alles bei Rausspringen, bei dieser verrückten Tabellenkonstellation. Eine Mannschaft, die mich etwas überrascht, dass sie noch so in der Musikveranstaltung drin ist, ist der FC Turin, die aktuell den 2. Europa League-Platz belegen. Mit 56 Punkten, ein Punkt gleich dahinter, Milan. Und dann ladest du schon mit ein bisschen Abstand. Aber die spielen da noch mittendrin in der Musik, haben auch aus den letzten sechs Spielen keines verloren. Drei Siege, drei Unentschieden. Jetzt folgt das Derby gegen Juve, hast du vorhin schon angesprochen. Was ist denn da beim FC Turin passiert, dass die auf einmal hier oben so mitmischen kurz vor Saisonende?
Das ist klarerweise die zweite schöne, sindarelle Geschichte. Also wenn es jetzt Atalanta nicht gäbe, dann wäre Turino da allein auch im Fokus zu Recht. Ja, logisch auch sehr emotionale Geschichte. Turino ist auch in Italien immer noch einer der am tiefsten verankerten, traditionellsten Vereine, wo auch wirklich von früher halt einfach auch noch viel Empathie auch von vielen anderen Seiten entgegengebracht wird. Und dass die jetzt da mitten im Champions League Rennen sind. Letzte Woche haben sie Milan geschlagen am Wochenende, haben sich da jetzt endgültig da quasi da vorne positioniert. Ja, logisch ganz, ganz super Geschichte. Und bei Turino ist es ein bisschen anders als bei Atalanta. Also der Trainer ist Walter Mazzari, der ja früher auch bei Napoli lange die Geschicke geleitet hat, der in der Zwischenzeit in England war. Und das hat sich einfach gefunden. Das passt wunderbar. Die spielen bei uns auf eine unfassbar starke Defensive. Also ich glaube, sie haben die zweitbeste Verteidigung der Liga oder so, nur ein paar Gegentore weniger als Juve.
29 Gegentreffer erst.
Genau.
Also die drittbeste hinter Inter und Juve.
Sie stehen wirklich sehr kompakt als Mannschaft. Sie sind auch als Mannschaft sehr unangenehm zu spielen, weil sie eine sehr robuste Mannschaft sind, körperlich stark. Also die beschäftigen dich auch sozusagen abseits des Balles. Das ist nicht angenehm, gegen die zu spielen. Und es kommt auch sehr viel Überlaufbereitschaft über Intensität. Und mit Bellotti, mit einem Kapitän, der ja vielleicht letzte Saison so ein bisschen Abfall hatte, der ja in den Jahren davor auch sehr regelmäßig getroffen hat, der kam jetzt auch wieder. Und ja, wirklich eine sehr, sehr schöne Geschichte. Also jetzt, du hast es angesprochen, am Freitag gibt es das Derby gegen Juve. Am Tag darauf ist der Jahrestag vom Flugzeugenglück, vom Grande Torino damals ins Berge eben. Also das Ganze, gerade auch Turin, da funkelt es momentan schon sehr, weil das wäre logisch eine riesen Nummer, wenn die das, wenn die – also klar, Europapokal wäre schon ein großes Kino, aber wenn die wirklich auch noch da am Ende in die Champions League noch reinspringen sollten, dann wäre das logisch eine unfassbar emotionale Geschichte. Und Torino ist ja jeder Verein, auch der in der Stadt so ein bisschen noch tiefer verankert ist und deswegen ist das ja, wie gesagt, also auch Respekt, was die da aufgezogen haben. Anders als Atalanta eben aus einer gesicherten Defensive, aber sehr unangenehm zu spielen und eine Mannschaft, die sich da wirklich rein gearbeitet hat sozusagen.
Und das Quäntchen, was fehlt, scheint ja die Offensive zu sein. Ich sehe 14 unentschieden, gleichzeitig sehe ich drittbeste Abwehr der Liga. Da vermute ich das eine oder andere 0 zu 0, 1 zu 1. Da wird der Kontrapunkt zu Atalanta sein und im Sturm ist dann so ein bisschen…
Ja, ich würde es, glaube ich, gar nicht mal unbedingt nur auf den Sturm. Es ist eine Mannschaft, die sehr viel über dieses Gegenballarbeiten kommt. Und Belotti liefert jetzt wieder sehr, sehr verlässlich. Sie haben eigentlich auf dem Papier, Sie haben auch Simone Zadzard haben sie noch geholt vor der Saison. Von dem kam ziemlich wenig, der hatte auch ein bisschen Verletzungsprobleme. Aber von dem haben sie definitiv mehr erwartet. Es war ein bisschen Hoffnung, dass Zadzard zusammen mit Belotti einen sehr robusten, wuchtigen Angriff bildet. Wie gesagt, Zadzard ist definitiv ein bisschen dahinter geblieben. Und dann hing halt doch oft viel an Belotti und an seinen Thoren. Und die kommen jetzt auch gerade auch wieder sehr verlässlich. Aber klar, jetzt alles allein schultern ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt einfach. Aber wie gesagt, Torino macht es halt einfach sehr genau über diese Kompaktheit. Und ja, wie du das richtig gesagt hast, das klappt dann halt auch nicht immer, dass du das da eine Tor mehr schießt. Und dann gibt es dann halt oft auch ein 1-1 oder halt eben auch ein 0-0. Und ja, klar, könnte das am Ende dann, könnten die paar Punkte hin fehlen. Ja, natürlich.
Aber das sind halt zwei Unbekannten mit Atalanta und bei Torino ja noch viel mehr. Die haben nichts zu verlieren. Klar. Im Gegensatz zu zwei Mannschaften, über die wir jetzt noch sprechen müssen, nämlich ja unter anderem Milan, die durch diese Niederlage jetzt eben rausgerutscht sind aktuell. Zwar punktgleich mit Turin, aber aktuell nicht mal Europa League spielen würden. Milan die ganze Saison, ach was, hier fast schon eine ganze Dekade jetzt irgendwie. So ein Patient haben wir ja auch schon jetzt häufiger drüber gesprochen. Wie ist denn der aktuelle Stand bei Mailand?
Ja, Milan ist definitiv logisch. Also wenn man die letzten Wochen, wenn man so eine Fieberkurve sich anschaut von diesen Mannschaften, dann ist es die halt mit der ja eindeutig mit dem negativsten Trend. Also Gattuso hat es ja eigentlich, Gattuso hat es nicht einfach, wurde ja auch oft manchmal gerade am Anfang so ein bisschen belächelt auch von vielen Seiten, aber hat es dann wirklich eigentlich so bis Dezember, Januar hat er die wirklich sehr gut auf Mordor Vordermann gebracht. Also es kam auch am Anfang ausgehend von einer stabilen Defensive, aber da gab es auch definitiv spielerische Ansätze und man hatte so das Gefühl okay, der bringt jetzt da den Drive rein und die fahren da jetzt in die Top 4 rein, was sie brauchen, auch finanziell, da gibt es ja große Geschichten drum herum. Aber in den letzten Wochen muss man klarerweise sagen, ist da einiges ins Stocken geraten und jetzt haben sie die Quittung bekommen und jetzt haben sie eine happige Aufgabe vor sich, um da noch reinzukommen. Denn wie gesagt, die anderen kommen, haben wir ja schon thematisiert, mit viel Euphorie, mit wenig zu verlieren und man merkt auch Gattuso ein bisschen an. Ich meine, dass Gattuso ein Kämpfer ist, glaube ich, muss man niemandem erzählen, auch in seiner neuen Position jetzt als Trainer, aber man merkt ihm auch an, dass das auch sehr viel Kraft gekostet hat. Es gab eben auch immer wieder Diskussionen um seine Position und deswegen bin ich sehr gespannt, ob die wirklich noch die Kurve kriegen. Was trotz aller negativen Tendenzen ein bisschen für sie sprechen könnte, ist der Kalender. Also wenn man sich den Vergleich anschaut, dann spielen sie jetzt, glaube ich, gegen drei oder sogar vier Mannschaften, für die es um nicht mehr viel geht.
Polonia, Fiorentina, Frosinone und Spal.
Genau, richtig, aus unterschiedlichen Gründen. Aber wie gesagt, der Trend ist momentan nicht Milans Friend.
Ein Sieg aus den letzten sieben Spielen.
Ja, und auch wieder diese Offensivprobleme, die es am Anfang der Saison gab. Denn irgendwann hatte er Defensive im Griff, aber dann ist vorne nicht viel passiert. Hat sich so mit Piontek auch im Winter schon ein bisschen gelöst, nicht nur Piontek allein, da hat er auch gut Bälle bekommen. Aber irgendwie in den letzten Wochen ist da wieder der Wurm drin und da kommt spielerisch momentan ziemlich wenig. Es gab auch immer wieder – Katusa hat jetzt auch irgendwann schon vor ein paar Wochen gesagt, er sagt nichts mehr zu seiner Rolle. Also es gibt auch viele, die vermuten, dass er vielleicht sogar von allein nach der Saison sagt, kommt, das lassen wir jetzt erst mal lieber bleiben, weil Anspruch und Wirklichkeit dann vielleicht doch auch ein bisschen auseinander liegen. Wobei jetzt bei aller Negativität, die man momentan auch ein bisschen bei Milan zeichnen muss, man darf eines nicht vergessen, wenn man sich den Stamm anschaut von der Milan-Mannschaft, dann ist das jetzt eine Mannschaft – ich habe es mir mal angeschaut, wenn du dir das acht oder neun Stammspieler anschaust, die sind alle um die 2, 23 oder jünger rum. Also da ist schon strukturell was geschaffen worden, das geht ja los logisch mit Donnarumma im Tor, mit Romagnoli eben, die ganze Abwehr sind eigentlich alles junge italienische Nationalspieler, die auch sicher in den nächsten Jahren da eine tragende Rolle haben werden. Du hast Biontech, der ist 23, du hast Cutrone, der 21, Paquetà, der Brasilianer, der im Winter kam, der wirklich viele Elemente gebracht hat, der glaube ich auch 2 oder 23 ist, Cassi ist 22, also da ist schon was da, das ist jetzt nicht eine, sag ich mal, wie es oft vielleicht früher war, so eine da hingerotzte Milan-Mannschaft, wo man sich gefragt hat, was hat die eigentlich noch mit dem großen Milan von früher zu tun, sondern da ist definitiv auch eine Basis geschaffen worden, mit der man einen klarer Plan auch dahinter sozusagen, den Leonardo und Malini, die ja da in der Verantwortung stehen, auch vorangetrieben haben. Also vielleicht braucht es da halt einfach die Francescos zum Beispiel, da fällt sehr oft der Name der Ex-Roma-Trainer, weil er dafür steht, dass er mit jungen Spielern sehr gut arbeiten kann. Also vielleicht braucht es da einfach ein bisschen Impuls von außen. Das Spielermaterial ist definitiv da, um da auch mittelfristig was aufzubauen und eben wie gesagt das Ganze dann auch in eine positive Richtung zu bringen. Wie es in dieser Saison endet, hui, schwierig.
Ja, apropos Impuls von außen, das ist mir eben aufgefallen, Milan hatte eine Phase, da haben sie nur gewonnen. Also die hatten dann am Schluss fünf Siege am Stück und dann kommt das Derby gegen Inter, das geht 2 zu 3 verloren und seitdem in sieben Spielen einen Sieg, vier Niederlagen, zwei Unentschieden.
Dieses Derby war definitiv so ein, hilft mir kurz, jetzt stehe ich auf dem Nacktpunkt. Ja genau, weil bei Inter ging es eben in die andere Richtung. Also Milan war der klare Favorit in dem Derby, das ist ja immer so eine Geschichte, dass er bei Derbys oft nicht wirklich hilfreich ist.
Und es war damals eben Dritte gegen Viertel.
Genau, richtig war auch direkt das Ding. Milan kam ja auch von hinten, ist dann auch an Inter vorbei sozusagen. Und bei Inter hat sich das eben ins Positive, da wurden all diese ganzen Icardi-Diskussionen, wo logisch alle im Verein leid waren, nur noch darüber zu reden, sind dann plötzlich mit diesem Sieg auch sehr euphorisch ins Positive umgemünzt worden. Und bei Milan ist genau dieser Rückschlag gekommen. Also immer wieder faszinierend, klar man hört ja oft, oh, diese Derbys, vielleicht werden die auch ein bisschen überbewertet, aber in dem Fall war es wirklich so eine Nummer, die zumindest emotional definitiv die einen sozusagen einen Schub nach oben gegeben hat und den anderen halt definitiv so ein bisschen einen Tritt nach unten.
Ja, und Milan ist jetzt natürlich gerade im aktuellen totalen Katastrophen-Modus, weil der Sturz von den Champions League-Rängen direkt raus aus dem kompletten internationalen Ring, der ist jetzt genau an diesem Spieltag passiert. Also von Platz 4 jetzt auf Platz 7 rausgefallen, zeigt natürlich auch, wie eng das gerade ist, aber da kann man vielleicht ein bisschen vergleichen mit dem HSV, der auf einmal aus den Aufstiegsrängen rausgerutscht ist. Da laufen gerade alle Sirenen auf.
Definitiv, wobei man da auch hinzufügen muss, das große Ding ist einfach für Vereine wie die Roma und auch Milan ist die Champions League. Also ich würde jetzt mal sagen, wenn es jetzt, das wird ja klarerweise keiner bestätigen, aber wenn es jetzt so kommen sollte, dass die Champions League nicht klappt, dann bin ich mir sicher, dass du intern bei Milan einige finden würdest, die dir sagen, dann sparen wir uns auch diese Europa League und reisen nach Baku oder schieß mich tot und konzentrieren uns wirklich voll auf die Liga, was man ja auch manchmal wirklich auch sieht, was logisch ein Vorteil sein kann, wenn dann die anderen diese Doppelbelastung in der Europa League haben. Und weil das sind einfach die finanziellen Gegebenheiten, gerade bei so einem großen Verein wie Milan, der ja auch einige offene Thematik noch mit der UEFA hat, einfach so – also ich würde sagen, es ist Champions League oder nichts. Logisch würden die die Europa League spielen, nicht falsch verstehen.
Aber es ist trotzdem unglaublich, wie die Europa League runtergewirtschaftet wurde.
Leider, klar, keine Frage. Aber das Schöne ist ja, also Vereine wie Atalanta und Torino sind wie gemacht, sieht man ja auch an der Eintracht wieder, da schließt sich der Kreis. Die würden da mit Euphorie reingehen, da brauchen wir gar nicht drüber reden. Leider, für so Vereine wie Milan oder ich würde die Roma da glaube ich auch dazu zählen. Also wenn ich die nächstes Jahr in der Europa League sehe, dann sehe ich, habe ich schon ein paar Spiele von mir in der Gruppenphase von mir, wo nicht sehr viel Drive drin ist. Freizeit auch mal anders gestalten kann als beim Fußball.
Es ist ja nicht die Schuld der Vereine, die jetzt den Wettbewerb nicht anzunehmen, es ist die Schuld der Top-Vereine, die die Champions League finanziell so sehr von der Europa League haben entwachsen lassen, in Zusammenarbeiten oder UEFA. Da haben sich halt ein paar, die eh schon die größten Messer haben, die haben sich das größte Stück vom Bruch gehabt. Und das merken wir aber halt an solchen Diskussionen, die wir nicht nur in Deutschland haben, sondern auch in Italien, in Spanien, überall. Es stellt sich dann die Frage, was passiert denn bei Lazio? Sollten die das internationale Geschäft verpassen? Die haben aktuell mit 55 Punkten. Ist es zwar nur ein Dreier, der viel zur Europa League, zur Champions League sind es vier Punkte. Aber wenn ich mir da die Bilanz der letzten Spiele angucke, dann sehe ich da erstaunlich viele Niederlagen, nämlich drei in den letzten sechs Spielen.
Ja, Lazio hat sich auch so ein bisschen – ich würde mal sagen, wenn man sich dieses ganze Rennen anschaut, dann ist Lazio ein bisschen ruhig geworden. Einsteigend sollte man sagen, die stehen auch im Pokalfinale. Es heißt ja dann Lazio gegen Atalanta in Rom, was logisch auch eine schöne Nummer ist. Da gibt es auch auf Lazio Seite wirklich – ich glaube, am ersten Verkaufstag haben sie ihnen die Tickets aus der Hand gerissen. Also Lazio hat sich auch in den letzten Jahren so ein bisschen in einer Pokalmannschaft entwickelt. Also klar, wenn die am Ende einen Pokal holen würden, dann wäre das logisch eine große Nummer für die, keine Frage. Ja, es ist auch so ein bisschen Sand ins Getriebe reinbekommen. Also Lazio, die großen Namen, die da ja definitiv da sind, zum Beispiel Milinkovic, Savic und so. Luis Alberto, auch Immobile mit abstrichen. Also Milinkovic, Savic spielt für seine Verhältnisse eine sehr unauffällige Saison. Also da war ja am Anfang dieses, ok, da war die WM und viel Aufmerksamkeit. Das dachte man vielleicht am Anfang, dass sich das vielleicht erst mal ein bisschen zeitlich fangen muss. Aber da kam danach jetzt auch nicht wirklich so viel. In Sagi, Lazio stand ja auch mal lange für einen auch sehr eigentlich attraktiven Stil. Also da war auch immer gut was los. Das ist auch ein bisschen weniger geworden. Also, ja, ich würde mal sagen, Lazio plätschert so ein bisschen vor sich hin, ist aber trotzdem noch im Spiel. Darf man nicht vergessen. Ich glaube, es gibt noch Lazio-Atalanta zum Beispiel. Also wenn ich mich auch recht entsinne, ist es sogar in Rom.
Das ist gleich jetzt am nächsten Spiel.
Genau, das stimmt jetzt schon. Also die können da quasi mit einem Sieg im direkten Weltkönig bis auf einen Punkt an Atalanta rankommen. Und wenn man sich dann anschaut, Kaljarri, Bologna, und dann am Ende gäbe es eventuell noch mal so ein Endspiel mit Turin. Also da ist definitiv auch noch die Chancen, sind schon da. Aber Lazio, so gefühlt würde ich sagen, hat sich Lazio so ein bisschen, Turin und Atalanta klammern man da logisch aus, aber ja, schon einen kleinen Schritt hinter den anderen Großen sozusagen. Also so wie sie momentan in der Tabelle dastehen, ist das vielleicht momentan auch das, was ihr Potenzial widerspiegelt. Und dann wird sich Ligada, um das kurz abzuschließen, die große Frage im Sommer, bleiben die großen Namen oder wird dann doch wieder einer vielleicht mal zu wirklich viel Geld gemacht.
Gut, bei Lazio ist jetzt aber auch schon wieder so viel neben dem Platz passiert, dass es da dann auch gar nicht so schwer fallen muss, wenig Mitleid mit Lazio in der Aktuellen Station zu haben. Sag ich jetzt einfach mal an dieser Stelle ganz offen, googelt das, wenn ihr nicht weißt, wovon ich spreche. Reicht, wenn ihr Mussolini Lazio angibt. Dann kommen die entsprechenden Ergebnisse. Lass uns noch wenigstens kurz auf das Ende der Tabelle blicken, beziehungsweise bevor wir auf das komplette Ende gehen, können wir vielleicht über zwei Mannschaften kurz sprechen, die jetzt mit guten Serien sich da Luft verschafft haben. Zum einen Spal, die jetzt aus den letzten sechs Spielen vier gewonnen haben, eine Niederlage, ein Unentschieden. Und Bologna, die jetzt gerade in den letzten vier Spielen ungeschlagen, drei Siege, ein unentschiedene, richtige Serie gestartet haben. Und das ist ja so wie oben die Serien, die anderen Vereine stressen. Stress, dass jetzt hier unten einige, die auf einmal wieder in Abstiegsgefahr geraten. Was ist da passiert?
Definitiv. Also, ich würde sagen, man kennt es ja oft auch aus anderen Ligen, dass der Abstiegskampf ja oft schon ein Schneckchenrennen ist.
Du wirst ja nicht, welche Liga du dabei kennst.
Weiß auch nicht, wen ich gerade im Hinterkopf habe. Aber das war dieses Jahr in Italien also wirklich komplett anders. Also, da sind auch Mannschaften hinten drin und man kann sich auch alle anschauen. Also, da wurden regelmäßig Dreier jetzt zuletzt geholt. Da kamen, wie du richtig sagst, plötzlich Mannschaften da hinten rein gerutscht, weil die konnten so schnell gar nicht schauen, dass plötzlich die Direktekorentz vier Punkte in zwei Spielen geholt hat. Und dann waren die plötzlich drin. Also, ich finde den Kampf gegen den Abstieg dieses Jahr hochqualitativ sozusagen. Und du hast genau Spall und Bologna sind da die zwei Beispiele. Also, fangen wir kurz mit Bologna an. Da hat wirklich Sinisa Mihailović, der da im Winter übernommen hat, wirklich diesen Drive reinbekommen. Bologna war für mich auch immer vom Spielermaterial her. Wir hatten die da ganz unten nichts verloren. Und Mihailović hat es jetzt geschafft, das quasi auch in der Gemüse umzumünzen. Da wurden im Winter Sansone, Soriano geholt. Auch zwei Namen, die hier in Deutschland auch noch ein Begriff sind. Die haben auch personell draufgepackt. Da ist dieser Erik Pulgar, chilenischer Nationalspieler im zentralen Mittelfeld, der wirklich eine herausragende Saison spielt, der die da wie auch schon letztes Jahr sehr, sehr trägt. Wo ich auch sehr gespannt bin, wo dessen Weg hingehen wird. Denn der ist meiner Meinung nach ein sehr guter, bringt sehr viel mit. Und ja, völlig zu Recht, dass die sich da jetzt da hinten rausgearbeitet haben. Denn mit dem Material haben die einfach da ganz unten nichts verloren. Und das hat Mihailović geschafft. Punkt. Und das Ball, ja, wieder so ein kleines Märchen. Letztes Jahr war es ihr erster Saison. Viel Euphorie kennt man, haben es geschafft. Das ist die Frage, zweite Saison. Und Respekt, was die da wieder auf die Beine gestellt haben. Man muss ja vielleicht um ganz kleine Klammer. Die haben vor 5 oder 6 Jahren noch in der 4. Liga gespielt. Also die haben wirklich einen beeindruckenden und sehr aber nachhaltigen Weg hinter sich. Also das ist nicht so eine hohe Höhe geschossen. Die haben ein kleines eigenes Stadion. Also da stimmt einfach sehr viel. Da gibt es immer noch Spieler, die in der 4. Liga gespielt haben, die heute jetzt auch noch da im Kader stehen und auch noch spielen. Zum Beispiel dieser Manuel Lazzari. Auch der ist mittlerweile italienischer Nationalspieler geworden. Der wird von Napoli umgarnt, von sehr vielen italienischen großen Vereinen. Ancelotti ist anscheinend großer Bewunderer oder es soll einer sein, der wirklich nachhaltig, der auch Druck macht. Der hat damals noch mit den in der 4. Liga gespielt und der hat jetzt diesen Weg eben zusammen mit dem Verein in die Serie A gemacht, ist zum Nationalspieler geworden und deswegen Respekt, dass die das da jetzt auch am Ende relativ souverän über die Runden bringen, wie du eben sagst. Ja, haben auch noch Juve zum Beispiel da geschlagen, so als kleines Emotional, wo Juve die Meisterschaft da von uns haben quasi in dem Moment. Haben aber auch andere, wie gesagt, geschlagen. Also, schöne Geschichte, definitiv.
Und hintendrin gibt es jetzt ein paar Geschichten, die sich dann für die beteiligten Vereine ein bisschen weniger schön lesen. Also wir haben eben mit Sball und Bologna Sball 39 Punkte, Bologna 37. Dann ein paar Mal mit 37, so ein bisschen die Frage, wie wir die dazu rechnen. Es sind acht Punkte von gesprungen, also die sind im Grunde raus. Aber hinten Genua, Udinese, Empoli, da sprechen wir über 35 Punkte, 33 Punkte und 29 Punkte. Was glaubst du, wie viel kann da noch passieren?
Also fangen wir mit Empoli an, weil mir das echt so ein bisschen im Herzen weh tut. Ich habe die Saison auch öfters kommentieren dürfen. Und fußballerisch ist irgendwie eine traurige Geschichte, weil die in richtig feinem Ball spielen. Also das ist wirklich auch ein Empolisspiel. Kann man echt nur sagen, ich habe die in Turin gesehen, auch bei vielen großen. Auch zu Hause, die haben jetzt auch Napoli zu Hause geschlagen, um da haben noch mal so ein bisschen Hoffnung geschöpft. Das ist eine Mannschaft, die spielt Fußball, die war glaube ich irgendwie...
43 Tore.
Ja, genau. Auch, ich glaube die waren so im November oder so, die hatten die die vierthöchste Ballbesitzquote in der Liga. Solche Geschichten, also es sind jetzt nur kleine Bauspiele, aber es zeigt Bausteine, das zeigt, die wollen Fußball spielen, die können auch Fußball spielen. Die haben unfassbar interessantes Mittelfeld, da gibt es drei relativ junge, also Traoré, einer aus der Alpenbeinküste, der ist 19, der fand, also überragende Anlagen, kann da mehr oder weniger alle Positionen spielen. Dann gibt es Ben Nasser, das ist ein, ich glaube Marokkaner, als will ich es nicht falsch sagen, auch ein richtig guter Kicker, an dem auch schon Arsenal länger dran sein soll, also ein sehr eleganter zentraler Mittelfeldspieler. Und Krunic, noch ein bosnischer Nationalspieler, der auch für die Bosnien jetzt auch erstmals in der Nationalmannschaft getroffen hat. Die haben gar nichts in der 2. Liga verloren. Also das schlimme Fanpolis logisch, die werden auch nicht in der 2. Liga landen, logischerweise. Und es geht da ja auch immer einher, wie willst du, die haben echt ein paar Juvelen, da gibt es auch Silveste, die Lorenzo, ein Außenverteidiger, der auch so im Dunstkreis der Nationalmannschaft ist, ein junger Italiener. Die haben echt gute Kicker, haben ein gutes System, aber das witzige ist, sie haben eigentlich sogar einen Knipser vorne drin mit Caputo, so ein 31-jähriger Italiener, der in seiner ersten Song, glaube ich, jetzt 14 oder 15 Buden hat. Aber irgendwie haben sie ganz oft, war so der Klassiker, sie spielen und spielen und spielen mit und machen aber die Buden nicht. Und dann steigst du leider am Ende ab, weil eben dieses Jahr die Konkurrenz jetzt gerade am Ende aus wirklich fleißig punktet und sie das leider zuletzt nicht mehr gemacht haben und auch einige direkte Duellen verloren haben, gegen Bologna verloren, gegen Spal verloren. Ja, sonst 4 Punkte Rückstand. Und ich würde es ihnen so sehr wünschen, dass sie noch mal reinschnuppern, aber…
Es ist ein hammerhartes Restprogramm. Wir spielen jetzt noch bei der, ne gegen die Föhrer und Tieren zu Hause, Sampdoria, dann gegen den FC Turin und dann gegen Inter. Und wenn wir uns vergleichen, es geht ja nur noch gegen Udinese, die 4 Punkte Vorschritte haben, wenn man realistisch ist. Und die spielen jetzt noch zwar zu Hause gegen Inter, aber dann auswärts in Frosinone, dann zu Hause gegen Spall, für die ja dann alles jetzt durch ist.
Genau, Kaljari auch alles durch. Nee, es spricht leider nicht viel für Empoli. Und ja, ist so ein klassischer Fall von… Also, den kannst du… Also, ich finde, da kannst du dem Verein auch schwer was vorwerfen, programmatisch, von den Leuten her, von der Spielidee. Aber klar, wenn dir am Ende die Punkte fehlen, wenn dir am Ende die Tore… Die haben ja auch nicht wenig Tore geschossen, aber dann, das ist einfach, ja…
Ich meine, ein bisschen zu viel gefangen. Ja, keine Affe mit 66 Gegensprachen.
Logisch, klar, es gibt auch viele Sachen, die… Aber wirklich, ich kann es nur, weil ich sie wirklich ein paar Mal gesehen habe, die sind nirgendwo aus der Arena geschossen worden. Auch nicht bei Juve. Die sind zum Beispiel, die kann ich mir noch ganz genau erinnern, die kommen nach Turin und spielen Ball bis jetzt. Aber nicht so von wegen, wir ändern jetzt alles und schauen, sondern die haben da echt auch, das war auch so ein Klassiker, dann spielen die eine richtig gute erste Hälfte, müssten eigentlich die Pude machen, weil sie zwei, drei Dinge haben, machen sie nicht, Juve macht es 1-0.
Es sind die kleinen Dinge, aber die schreiben ja dann manchmal auch die großen Geschichten in der Liga. Mensch, jetzt haben wir wieder echt viel über die Serie A gelernt, wie ich finde. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie sich das da oben raus noch gestalten wird.
Also da lohnt sich definitiv ein Blick, würde ich sagen, in den nächsten Spieltagen, weil es auch in den letzten zwei, drei Spieltagen schon so war, da hat sich auch in den Spielen dann immer viel verändert, weil auch dadurch durch diese direkten Duelle, da kann ja echt mit einem Schlag plötzlich, eben wie gesagt, wir hatten es gerade, lass jetzt Lazio und Atalanta schlagen, dann sind die auch wieder mittendrin. Also das ist wirklich eine spannende Nummer.
Absolut. Dann sollte man jetzt mitverfolgen. Und vielleicht müssen wir gucken, Bernie, ob wir das noch hinkriegen. Vielleicht müssen wir nach der Saison noch ganz kurz sprechen, wie es ausgegangen ist. Ich habe dann den Royale an der Backe. Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich da noch irgendwas einschieben kann.
Wenn du es in deine Projekte einpflanzen kannst, dann sehr gerne. Einen allerletzten Satz nur noch, Max. Wir sehen hier Kiewo an allerletzter Stelle. Und klar, die Punkte, 15 Punkte, die waren schon früh raus. Lass uns da vielleicht noch sagen, Kiewo war jetzt zwölf Jahre in Serie A. Und das ist wirklich die Definition eines kleinen Vereins. Und klar, in dieser Saison, wenn man drauf steht, Kiewo geht runter und das schlechteste Mannschaft Europas, Pipapo, ja. Aber man sollte nicht vergessen, finde ich, dass es allein in dem Moment, wo es jetzt bei denen zu Ende geht, zumindest für diese Saison, dass ich es eine unfassbare Leistung finde, dass Mannschaften aus diesem Segment, wenn du es dann echt wirklich schaffst, zwölf Jahre am Stück dich quasi in der höchsten Liebe zu...
Ja krass, ich hätte dich jetzt gar nicht so als kleinen Verein abgestellt. Aber dann hast du so FC Augsburg, FC Freiburg, Mainz 05 so in dir.
Kiewo ist ja nicht mal ein Stadtteil von Verona so ungefähr. Also es ist wirklich, klar, die haben so viele Märchen auch geschrieben, die waren ja auch mal kurzzeitig sogar in Europapokal. Und die haben halt wahrscheinlich auch nach außen hin so ein bisschen alle verwöhnt. Und ja, jetzt hat sie sie halt mal erwischt, aber ich glaube nach zwölf Jahren darfst du dich auch mal erwischen. Und ich traue denen definitiv zu, dass die da nächste Saison das Ganze wieder vielleicht sogar schon relativ schnell umkehren können.
Es ist auf jeden Fall eine Saison zu vergessen, bei zwei Siegen und 20 Niederlagen. Aber so eine Saison gibt es ja mal, dann steigt man ab. Gucken wir mal, vielleicht sprechen wir ja dann in zwei Jahren.
Wer weiß.
Serie B werden wir jetzt nicht direkt auch mit aufnehmen. Aber vielleicht in zwei Jahren nochmal drüber. Ich danke dir sehr herzlich, dass du dir mal wieder die Zeit genommen hast, hierher zu kommen.
Ja, vielen Dank Max, dir großen Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich. Und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit hier in diesem Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 126. Bis bald, macht's gut, ciao.